Jada is ordering Mother's
Day gifts online.
The shipping costs are based on
the dollar amount of the order.
For orders less than
$20, shipping costs $4.
For orders $20 or
more, shipping is $7.
Can the dollar
amount of the order
be represented as a
function of shipping costs?
So they're saying,
can the dollar amount
of the order-- so can
the amount of order
be represented as a
function of shipping--
let me do that in
that blue color costs.
So if we have the shipping
costs as an input,
will that map to exactly--
for a given input,
will we get exactly one output
for the amount of order?
In order for this to be
represented as a function,
we have to input a shipping
cost, a shipping cost
where this relationship
is defined.
We need to input
a shipping cost,
put it into our relationship,
and get exactly one dollar
amount of the order in order
for this to be a function.
If we get multiple dollar
amounts of the order, then
the relationship, well,
it's still a relationship,
but it's not going
to be a function.
So let's think about it.
What are the
possible inputs here?
Well, there's only two
possible shipping costs.
Shipping costs are
either going to be $4,
or they're going to be $7.
So let's think
about what happens
when we input $4 in
as a shipping cost.
So if we input $4
into our relationship,
so we input $4 into our
little potential function box,
so $4 into it,
what is the output?
What is going to be the
amount of the order?
Well, if the shipping cost is
$4, the amount of the order
just has to be
anything less than $20.
So it could have been $1.
It could have been $1.50.
It could've been $7.
It literally can take
on any value up to $20.
So it could even be $19.99.
We could do a similar
thing if we input 7
into this relationship.
If 7 was-- and I could put
literally an infinite number
of numbers.
It could be a million dollars.
So if I input 7 into
this relationship
that we're trying to test
whether it's a function, if 7
is the shipping costs,
then the order we just know
is over $20, $20 or more.
So it could be $20.
It could be $800.
It could be $1 million.
There's actually an
infinite number of values
that it could take
on right over here.
So because for a
valid shipping cost,
for each of these
valid shipping costs,
I can get many, many,
many potential outputs,
I don't know which output it
necessarily will output to.
If someone tells you
the shipping costs
and you don't necessarily
know what the order size was,
this is not a function.
You cannot represent the
amount of order as a function
of the shipping cost.
So, no.